-It is time for our
latest installment of
"Tonight Show Polls."
Here we go.
-♪ "Tonight Show Polls" ♪
-This first poll asks...
-Oh.
-This next poll asks...
"The 'n."
This next one asked...
What?
This next one asks...
Interesting.
This next one is interesting.
This next poll asks,
"Do you prefer sitting
in a booth or at a table?"
What do you think, Higgins?
-I'm going to say booth.
-Yeah. What do you think, Tariq?
You feel like a
booth type of guy.
-I'm definitely a booth person.
-Quest?
-Booth.
-I think everyone goes
booth, right?
-I think.
Let's see what the poll says.
-Alright. 55% said...
-[ Laughs ]
Oh!
Indeed!
French fries? Feed them to me.
-I love sharing
my food with you.
-Mmm! Open the door!
-[ Laughs ]
Open the hangar!
We're adults. There we go.
This next poll asks...
This next poll asked...
♪ Softly, slowly ♪
[ Vocalizing ]
[ Laughter ]
The last poll asked...
That's all the time we have for
"Tonight Show Polls."
What a great show tonight.